le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
fondé il ya 30 ans par l'ancien maire de
cilaos l'établissement irénée accot tu
es le seul centre thermal de l'océan
indien
en travaux depuis des années il a décidé
d'offrir une cure de jouvence ces trois
derniers mois
en investissant sur du matériel et de
l'aménagement une occasion pour les
curistes où le public de passage de
redécouvrir ce lieu historique de cilaos
[Musique]
à 90 ans clément mounoussamy vient tous
les ans faire secure pendant 18 jours
atteint d'une sciatique
il vient depuis 17 ans à cilaos un cadre
qu'il connaît bien prendre garde le
personnel des jeunes
le gentil synami athènes on ajoute les
quelque chose qu'on peut voir si la rose
les routes fleuries le paysage par
claire tu le fais actuellement au stade
avec tout ça n'incite qu'à venir pour
chercher la santé
les travaux ont refait s'améliore on ne
sait pas là que ya pas de temps mort la
loi
trois mois et demi de fermeture 600000
euros de travaux
les thermes de cilaos avait besoin d'une
cure de jouvence pour accueillir les
visiteurs
l'établissement a rouvert ses portes le
13 octobre dernier les gros plus gros
changement qui a eu dans cet espace là
bas c'est effectivement la bande
d'acteurs a été déplacé et totalement
remplacer
travaux de peinture au plafond sur les
murs et
traitement du sol aussi dans les quatre
dents avec la pose du revêtement
la première session de 65 curistes a
découvert les lieux après les travaux
bonjour à toi aussi tu veux pas qu à
whisky cinq ans et alors ça va de mieux
en mieux et c'est très bien
et qu'est ce que tu penses fait des
travaux qui ont été réalisés ça l'est
vraiment beaucoup d'améliorations voilà
c'est super
depuis des années on réalise des travaux
mais qui sont assez minimes et on a vu
qu au niveau des baignoires au niveau
des cabines au niveau du carrelage
l'établissement dans son ensemble avait
besoin d'être relooké et aujourd'hui ce
qui est intéressant ce qui est bien
c'est que les curistes apprécié ce
changement apprécié ces travaux et nous
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que la
notoriété de l'établissement thermal de
cilaos aille au delà de cilaos
créée en 1987 par l'ancien maire de la
ville
irene a corte les termes sont le seul
établissement thermal de l'océan indien
une clientèle surtout réunionnaise et
10% de curistes de métropole viennent
profiter des vertus d'une eau riche en
fer les spas jacuzzis qui est ici on
rentre il y avait un mauvais
l'anciennement et il a été remplacé en
juin juin juillet on a deux clientèle
importante au sein d'établissements une
qui concerné par l'aspect médical au
travers des kurdes sont proposés donc ça
se fait en matinée entre 7h et 12h une
heure et ensuite l'après-midi à tout ce
qui concerne la remise en forme la
détente le bien-être donc à partir d'une
heure et demie jusqu'à 17h ou là on
accueille tout type de public touristes
ou locaux qui viennent profiter des
équipements et des prestations qu'on
propose 13h30 c'est au tour des
touristes de venir se détendre
on est venus découvrir les thermes
depuis leur ouverture et l'idée pour
nous c'était après quatre jours de
randonnées dans mafate de passer
petite heure ou une heure et demie de
détente les termes et des femmes et
chaque fois qu'on s'est renseigné pour
nous avait expliqué que la réouverture
était prévue pour octobre
oui ça fait du bien ça renchérit second
face à rollers grâce à ces travaux les
thermes de cilaos et ses curistes
pourront encore profiter de cette source
et y couler des jours heureux pour les
30 prochaines années l'établissement
irénée accot tu fait ses 30 ans cette
année
ce centre thermal géré par le
département est le seul de l'océan
indien avec un investissement de 600
mille euros et trois mois de fermeture
les termes rouvrent leurs portes pour
accueillir les clients dans de
meilleures conditions
une remise à neuf du matériel et des
locaux qui profitera à un public composé
de curistes venant chercher l'aspect
médicinales mais aussi de la remise en
forme pour les touristes ou marcheurs
des alentours pour redécouvrir les
termes rénové vous pouvez les contacter
au 02 62 31 72 27 ou bien par mail en
vous rendant à l'adresse suivante
www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]